it's pretty rare that we record a
podcast and it goes up the next day yes
this one's going live tomorrow okay cool
and today happy thursday people yeah
dude [ __ ] right on today the
paramount pictures announced that
jackass forever is not in fact coming
out on october 22nd but they're pushing
it to february 4th
next year due to coven jackass for later
oh because it they want it in theaters
the delta yeah the delta
you know whatever so yeah february 4th
is the new release date my dad
speculates that covert is going to be
even worse
february
then you think so
i don't know
i mean i'm stoked for the new jackass
thanks man we were watching it's really
fun we just watched the the original
jackass movie like two months ago we
were still figuring out what we were
doing with the original jackass it was
just kind of felt like
you know it been it had its own quality
to it then jackass number two we had
figured out what we were doing that was
the masterpiece yeah jackass number
three was the biggest financial success
but like not even the best movie
and and this fourth one is uh
we'll never beat number two but we
smashed number three dude we [ __ ] we
walked all over number three dude like
in turn like financially no no no no no
no it's not out here
oh yeah it does yeah the quality wise
yeah i'm so [ __ ] good i'm so stupid
it's so [ __ ] good and uh dude so we
had this this call with the like the the
cast where they announced to us that
they're gonna push the movie
and and dave england's like no hands on
his head he's like you could just see
the agony in his face and i said dave
dude what are you talking about like the
trailer came out there's a big buzz
around the movie you know like we're
kind of hot [ __ ] right now and the
second that movie comes out we're washed
up losers again you know the more they
can kick it down the road the longer
we're hot [ __ ]
there you go you're like i hope this
thing never comes out right
carter finally i hope koben keeps
getting worse actually
carter five baby
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude